I'm an ass I'll show up in this if I say
matter have more pain tolerance and
women and then I'm just saying what
everyone wants to hear if I say women
have more pain tolerance than men so
we'll just find out I guess well I think
I read that women have proven to have
better pain tolerance in general I feel
like I've heard girls about a higher
pain tolerance and boys I think girls
have a higher pain tolerance than guys
do
[Music]
that stings
grab the bat sting it and hurts it there
it's really bad oh that hurts
what's cold it's like crawling in my arm
ah this is pleasant it feels fine so far
this kind of just reminds me of like
being on the ice and like skating around
and stuff in the winter ha ha all right
I want to do it oh it's very cold oh
yeah I'm actually keep thinking about
Titanic for some reason God is this what
the people with a Titanic felt like okay
yeah I'm done
the rest of my body is sweating do I
even have a hand anymore oh my god yeah
I don't like it if I leave my hand still
I think I'll be good I can't do it
anymore this hurts it's just more like
it's kind of like boring my hand is very
numb right now though okay now is all
right I can't move it right up to the
edge there all right that's enough
[Music]
I felt like the way I feel when I go on
a run
we're like it starts out really terrible
and I really don't want to be there and
then after a while you're like well this
is just the pain I feel for now so I
might as well just keep feeling it
[Music]
oh yeah yeah a nice warm bath that's
great can I bring this to my desk finish
this video I just this is this is okay
yeah I'm good how are you so good I
honestly don't know I did not expect
this to be me
I'm just gonna take my hand out here I
can't
i this is too painful do it I admitted
yeah do it take it out No you already
won so take it out all right all right
I missed you sweet